[Música]
en Ecuador el presidente Guillermo lasso
anunció que no se presentará a las
elecciones anticipadas la decisión Del
mandatario se conoció luego de que el
Consejo Nacional electoral presentará el
20 de agosto como fecha tentativa para
los comicios ampliamos
contrariamente a lo esperado por las
autoridades estadounidenses el número de
personas que intentan cruzar ilegalmente
la frontera se ha reducido hasta un 70%
tras el fin del título 42 tenemos
análisis sobre los motivos que impulsan
esta dinámica en la zona limítrofe
y la Casa Blanca reconoció que Aún
existen fuertes diferencias con la
contraparte republicana en busca de un
acuerdo que permita Elevar el techo de
la deuda a pesar de que se reporta poco
avance los diálogos el gobierno de Joe
biden se dice optimista
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un placer
estar con ustedes abrimos el Informativo
en Ecuador porque tras la disolución del
Congreso y luego que el Consejo Nacional
electoral propusiera el 20 de agosto
como fecha tentativa de las elecciones
el actual presidente Guillermo lasso
anunció que no se presentará a los
comicios anticipados las enfrentaba un
juicio político en la asamblea nacional
por presunto peculado cuando decidió
disolver el legislativo desde quito
Gustavo Ortega corresponsal de France 24
con los detalles
el anuncio lo realizó el presidente de
la república durante una entrevista
concedida a Washington post desde el
Palacio de carondelette Guillermo lasso
no buscará la reelección ni le interesa
quién será su sucesor afirmó al menos
así lo expresó el mandatario ecuatoriano
luego de disolver la asamblea nacional y
convocar a elecciones presidenciales
anticipadas Guillermo lasso aseguró que
él también se va y se dedicará a emitir
decretos ley en materia económica en los
seis meses de gestión que le quedan por
delante decretos que deberán contar con
el aval de la corte constitucional que
tendrá vigencia mientras no exista el
contrapeso legislativo y que podrán ser
renovados o derogados por el próximo
parlamento lazo criticó que se le afirme
que aplicó la muerte Cruzada para evadir
el juicio político y que según él
decidió acortar el período por el bien
del país afirmó que la decisión la tomó
una vez de estar seguro que contaría con
el apoyo de las fuerzas armadas Ecuador
va en rumbo un proceso electoral y con
ello se caliente el ambiente previo los
comicios ya se escuchan los nombres de
un ex vicepresidente un ex candidato a
la alcaldía de Quito un líder indígena y
un ex candidato a la vicepresidencia y
un ex asambleísta como postulantes a la
presidencia el Consejo Nacional
electoral tiene la obligación de
convocar a elecciones en siete días y
reunir a los Ecuatorianos en 90 días
frente las urnas tentativamente el 20 de
agosto sería la elección presidencial el
15 de octubre la segunda vuelta de
realizarse y el mes de noviembre la
posesión presidencial si este cronograma
es aprobado por el órgano comicial
Argentina experimenta una inflación
anual superior al 108% y tiene niveles
de pobreza que se acercan al 40%, sus
habitantes se enfrentan a dificultades
económicas que hacen muy difícil
planificar y sostener a sus familias los
ingresos en general pierden frente al
aumento de los precios en un contexto en
el que el gobierno encara el tramo final
de su mandato y en el que no tiene
demasiado margen de maniobra para saber
cómo se vive la situación en el país
suramericano nuestro corresponsal en
Buenos Aires nos envió el siguiente
informe
manifestaciones como estas son
habituales en la capital Argentina en
esta ocasión fueron miles de personas de
organizaciones que representan a
sectores de bajos ingresos con empleos
precarios o que se sostienen con ayuda
Estatal que consideran insuficiente
no alcanza si bien A mí tampoco me
alcanza yo pago un alquiler y yo creo
que ninguno de los compañeros que están
acá tampoco les alcanza ellos pues
tienen hijos tienen cuatro cinco seis
chicos cada uno y no les alcanza el
economista guido Zack explica que en un
país con casi 40% de pobreza y precios
que aumentaron más de 108% en los
últimos 12 meses la alta inflación no
impacta igual en toda la sociedad esto
se ve claramente en el mercado laboral
entre el segmento informal y el segmento
formal el segmento formal que en general
tienen un salario promedio más elevado
es un segmento que es más que mal sigue
la inflación y no tiene tanta pérdida
por adquisitivo el sector informal tiene
una pérdida de poder adquisitivo muy
significativa sin embargo el empleo en
el sector informal es el que más ha
crecido segmento del que forma parte
Pablo Julián Romero con algo de ayuda
Pablo comenzó un emprendimiento de
producción y venta de empanadas él es un
ejemplo de lo que le ha ocurrido a
muchos pasó del empleo formal y la
seguridad económica la informalidad
laboral y a vivir con lo justo del 2015
a esta parte que son 8 años
Yo fui como una la pendiente fue para
abajo Nunca fue para así que podría
haber sido y así no siempre fue
linealmente para abajo en mi caso hablo
Pablo tiene mucha expectativa de que el
negocio de las empanadas le permita
salir adelante y trata de no pensar en
la inestabilidad económica del país y la
amenaza que representa para proyectos
como el suyo
en Perú Alberto fujimori negó que
durante su gobierno se realizarán
esterilizaciones forzadas a mujeres el
expresidente apareció de manera
telemática desde el penal de barbadillo
a fujimori se le imputa la ejecución de
una política de planificación familiar
con esterilizaciones masivas sin embargo
él afirma que lo que se hizo fue reducir
la mortalidad de las mujeres y que todo
se hizo de manera libre
falso la
imputación
porque lo que hizo mi gobierno
fue
ofrecer a la población y en particular
de las mujeres
todos los métodos de planificación
familiar
moderno y
tradicionales sin excepción
sin preferencia por uno u otro a la
libre elección de cada una de las
interesadas en otras noticias el
departamento de seguridad Nacional de
Estados Unidos informó que los
encuentros con migrantes que buscan
llegar al país en la frontera con México
ha caído en un 70% desde el fin del
título 42 el pasado 11 de mayo a
medianoche oficiales del departamento
indicaron que más de 11.000 personas han
sido repatriadas esta semana esto el
tiempo que Fuentes gubernamentales
informaron que se han admitido a mil
migrantes diariamente provenientes de
Cuba Nicaragua y Venezuela como parte
del programa de Visas humanitarias
anunciado el pasado enero anteriormente
hablamos con Gladys cañas defensora de
los derechos de los migrantes allí en
México que preguntaba a qué se debe el
descenso de cruces irregulares cuando se
esperaba un aluvión tras la caída del
título 42
Así es efectivamente era
la preocupación
de México como el de Estados Unidos de
que hubiera un tumulto de gente en los
puentes internacionales y efectivamente
eso no sucedió
más del 50 al 70% de las personas de
cruce irregular disminuyeron Esto se
debe también a la al miedo que tienen
ellos a ser castigados por cinco años
De no poder hacer un trámite migratorio
en Estados Unidos al entrar de forma
irregular Y aunque la crisis fronteriza
aparece ceder dentro de las fronteras
estadounidenses el gobierno se enfrenta
a otra que podría traer graves
consecuencias las conversaciones con la
oposición republicana para Elevar el
techo de la deuda siguen estancadas y la
Casa Blanca reconoció que grandes
diferencias se mantienen entre las
partes tras Una pausa las negociaciones
retomaron brevemente el viernes en la
noche pero no se reportaron avances los
republicanos exigen recortes al gasto
público como una precondición para este
límite de endeudamiento de 31,4 billones
de dólares de no alcanzar un pacto la
primera Economía del mundo caería en
default por primera vez en su historia
así se pronunciaba la portavoz de la
Casa Blanca desde Japón
el presidente Confía en que hay un
camino para avanzar si ambas partes
vienen de buena fe él cree que podemos
lograrlo cuando se trata de establecer
Cómo vemos el presupuesto para el pueblo
estadounidense él es optimista Pero
nuevamente tiene que suceder de buena fe
y mira Así es como funcionan las
negociaciones cierto es un poco de toma
y daca Este es el núcleo de la
Democracia eso es lo que estamos viendo
un juego aquí y Mientras todos entiendan
que no se puede conseguir todo lo que se
quiere cuando hay negociaciones entonces
Este es un presidente que entiende esto
ha sido muy claro acerca de cuán
imperativo es lograr que esto se haga y
mira nos sentimos confiados y optimistas
cerramos con noticias espaciales un
equipo de la compañía espacial
Blue origin del Magnate y en bezos se
hizo con el contrato de la NASA para
construir la nave espacial que enviará
de nuevo astronautas a la luna bajo el
programa artemisco el contrato tiene un
valor aproximado de 3.400 millones de
dólares la misión está programada para
el final de la década y devolverá a los
humanos a nuestro satélite por primera
vez desde 1972
con estas imágenes de la luna Nos
despedimos sigan conectados a France 24
y France 24.com
[Música]